hi guys today we have a really exciting
video for you we are going to predict
who is going to win this year's ICC
Cricket World Cup the Cricket World Cup
is one of the biggest events on the
planet just like the Olympics and the
FIFA World Cup this tournament is hosted
every four years and this time it is
hosted by England and Wales there are 10
nations participating in this World Cup
we have South Africa India Australia
England New Zealand Pakistan Bangladesh
Sri Lanka Afghanistan and West Indies so
far we are done with 15 matches in the
tournament and New Zealand is in the
lead followed by England India and
Australia now let us have a look at the
team stats of each of these countries
they're important players and the
statistics of these players in ODI s--
so we are going to be throwing around a
lot of technical jargons related to
cricket very soon here are a few terms
that you need to know about batting
average it represents how many runs on
average of batsman scores before getting
out the higher the batting average the
better the batsman's ability to score
runs without getting out next we have
bowling economy this represents the
number of runs conceded per over it is
calculated by the number of runs
conceded divided by the number of overs
bowled first off we have South Africa
which is the only African nation that is
a part of this tournament the team is
led by the captain five two places who
has a batting average of forty five
point four three they have a world-class
opener Hashim Amla and cabeza Rapada who
is one of the best fast bowlers South
Africa has produced the South African
team has shown excellent performance in
the last five days and we can expect
them to perform similarly in this World
Cup as well India is one of the craziest
cricket following nations in the world
its popularity in cricket is unmatchable
captain Marat Kohli leads India he is
without a doubt one of the best
cricketers in the world his batting
average is close to 60 they also have
Rohit Sharma who is popularly known as
the hit man and just pre-poo Mehra who
is India's leading strike bowler
India has won two of its last 500
matches it played before the World Cup
lost three despite the recent losses
expectations are high for India to
perform well in this World Cup trigger
is one of the popular sports in
Australia added French captain's a team
who has a decent batting average of 39
point two five they have some really
talented players in the team such as
David Warner and Mitchell stark you can
see their career stats on the screen
Australia has done significantly well in
the last 500 days where they have won
all the five matches from the birthplace
of cricket we have one of the strongest
contenders for the World Cup team
England is led by oil Morgan who has a
batting average of 39 point three two
they have other great peers like Joe
root and Ben Stokes England won the last
four matches out of five with home
support they have a fairly good chance
to lift this trophy next we have New
Zealand who are popularly known as the
Kiwis they are being led by keen
Williamson who has a very good batting
average of 40 6.51 Ross Taylor and
martin Guptill are the other main
players in this team they have won four
out of the last five matches they have a
very high probability of winning this
time then we have Pakistan who are
captained by Sarfaraz Ahmed he has a
batting average of 40 6.51
the team also has other good batsmen
like [ __ ] Aman and Papa resumed their
statistics are displayed on the screen
looking at their previous 5 ODI
performances it seems Pakistan faces an
uphill struggle to win this World Cup
next up in the list we have another
Asian country Bangladesh it is being led
by Mustapha Murtaza who possesses a
bowling economy of 4.85 they have a good
opener Tamim Iqbal and one of the best
all-round O's in the world
Shakib Al Hasan considering the last
five Oh Tia is their performance has not
been very satisfactory now we will look
into a South Asian island country Sri
Lanka they are being led by the new
captain DeMuth Khurana Rodney who has a
batting average of 24.93 they also have
coucil Pereira and a world-class pace
bowler Lasith Malinga
of the last five matches they have lost
three drawn one and one another
analyzing their stats
it looks like Sri Lanka might have to go
through a bit of struggle to win this
World Cup
moving on to our next team which is
Afghanistan a team which has been
playing some good cricket they are being
led by Gill burden knife who is an
all-rounder and has a bowling economy of
5.25 Rajat Khan and Muhammad Nabeel are
the other good players in the team out
of the last five oh D I mattress they
have won - lost - and drawn one they
might be considered as an underdog team
but are still a force to be reckoned
with
finally hailing all the way from the
Caribbean region we have the West Indies
team
Jason holder captains the team he has a
bowling economy of five point five five
and can't bat as well Chris Gayle and
Andrew Russell are the two big hitters
present in the team they have performed
fairly well in the last five days the
windi's have a 50-50 chance of winning
this world cup now that we have been
introduced to the teams let's have a
look at their ICC ODI rankings leaving
the table we have team England followed
by India in the third position we have
South Africa followed by New Zealand
Australia Pakistan Bangladesh West
Indies Sri Lanka and finally Afghanistan
before we move into predicting who's
going to win this year's World Cup let's
look at the results of the last six
years in the year 1996 Sri Lanka lifted
the trophy the next three consecutive
tournaments were won by Australia from
1999 to 2007 in 2011 India won the World
Cup and in 2015
Australia became the champions again as
you can see on the screen we have the
entire schedule of this year's World Cup
it started on May 30th and will go on
until July 14th
each team will play against all the
other teams in a round-robin method the
round-robin is a very simple algorithm
it is a cyclic process which is easy to
implement based on the point scored by
each team the top four will qualify to
the semi-finals before we give out our
prediction we have simply learned want
to clarify that we are not biased
towards any team the results are purely
based on the performances of the teams
over the last few years we'll be using
the logistic regression machine learning
model to predict the winner so without
any further ado
let's get into the code we will first
start off by importing all the libraries
and dependencies we will be using pandas
and numpy for data manipulation and
analysis then we'll be using matplotlib
and Seabourn which is for data
visualization and finally we will be
using the scikit-learn library for
building the model using logistic
regression so now let's run this cell
next we'll be loading the data sets
we'll be loading the first file into the
world under scope variable and use
pandas library to read the data set the
second file into the results variable
let's have a look at both data sets this
is the first data set here we have all
the 10 teams and the number of times
they have played the World Cup and this
is the number of times they have won it
and these two columns represent the
number of times they have played the
finals and the semi-finals and finally
we have their current ODI rankings
moving on to a next data set this is the
results data set it represents all the
details of the ODI matches the teams
have played through the years 2010 to
2017 team 1 represents the home country
team 2 represents the of a country and
here we have the winner and this column
represents the margin by which the match
was won and finally we have the location
where the match was played so now let's
run this next let's display the head of
both data sets as you can see head
displays the first 5 rows of the data
set after that will filter the matches
played by India and display the results
so here are the first fire results of
the modified table let's now create a
column to display the details of matches
played in 2010 and take it as a
reference so as you can see we have a
new column called match here here and we
have filtered out the results for 2010
in the next piece of code will merge the
details of the teams participating in
this World Cup with their past results
drop the duplicates and get the count
let's now display the results of the
newly created data frame while doing
feature engineering we need to delete
certain columns from the data set that
won't affect the outcome of the
prediction process here we'll be
dropping the date margin and ground
columns so here we have the output of
the modified table now that we are done
with feature engineering let
start building the model we are going to
assign a label 115 won won the match and
label two if team two won it and then
check the results after this we need to
convert the categorical values to
continuous inputs using model underscore
selection method from scikit-learn
library we will split the data for
training and testing will be using 70%
data for training and the rest for
testing let's see the first five rows
from the final data now we are going to
train the model using the logistic
regression method using logistic
regression dot fit function will pass
the extreme and white train variables to
get the accuracy for training set and
testing set data we'll use log reg dot
score function so here you can see a
model training accuracy is 68% and test
accuracy is 66% now we will add the ICC
ranking data and the World Cup fixtures
data let's have a look at the data sets
this is the ICC rankings data here we
have all the ten teams and their
respective points here we have the
fixtures data set here we have the
entire schedule of the World Cup the
tournament started on the 30th of May
and it will go on until the 14th of July
we are going to store the data sets into
ranking and fixtures variables
respectively also using an empty list
pred set will store the results of the
league games now it's time to create new
columns with ranking position for each
team and slicing the data set for the
first 45 games we are doing this since
era only fortify league stage matches as
you see this is the output after this
we'll run a for loop to add teams to the
new prediction data set based on the
ranking position of each team then we'll
convert the list phred set into a data
frame and store it in a variable called
backup read set these are the first fair
results of the list spread set then we
need to get the dummy variables and add
missing columns to the training data set
by running a fourth loop here's the
output of the teams that are playing in
the World Cup for all the matches in the
next piece of code we predict the
results of all the league stage matches
so these are the probable winners of all
the group matches based on our
prediction
New Zealand England India and South
Africa are the four teams likely to
qualify for the semi-finals New Zealand
will play against India and England we
play against South Africa we will store
these teams in the form of a couple semi
this large block of code will be used to
get the result of the semi-finals by
creating a user-defined function clean
and predict the function accepts four
parameters this is the final step with
which we can obtain the result of the
winner of the ICC Cricket World Cup 2019
now we call the above defined function
and pass the parameters to get the
winners of the semi-finals as you see
here we have New Zealand playing against
India and the probable winner being
India similarly we have South Africa
playing against England and the probable
winner being England so we have the two
finalists India and England will store
these finalists into a tuple called
finals finally we'll call the clean and
ferric function to know who is winning
this World Cup and there we go we have
England being the probable winner of
this World Cup although the prediction
is favoring England the previous
performance of the teams isn't the only
factor that can assure its victory there
are numerous other factors that come
into play such as weather conditions
player injuries crowd support team
morale and much more and algorithm alone
cannot take into consideration the
prerequisites required for a team to win
a match let's just hope the best team
wins
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here